here's another film I've talked about a
lot on this website flight of the
navigator this is another one of those
often overlooked Disney films that
really needs more attention it's a
greater phenomenal no but it does such a
good job with its build-up and does come
around to giving kids a very fun fantasy
to partake in the idea of controlling
your own spaceship well kid will love
that idea the story centers around Davy
he's a common everyday boy who suddenly
falls into ditch and wakes up years
later his mom his dad his brother
everybody is age nobody quite knows why
but scientists have a theory that it
connects to the spaceship that suddenly
appeared the spaceship keeps sending him
messages in all sorts of different ways
and the scientists are trying to figure
out what the connection is the boy
eventually is drawn to the spaceship so
much that he goes to visit it and sure
enough the spaceship has an alien
creature inside that davy calls max who
says that davy and a bunch of other life
forms they he's taken from other worlds
we're all part of an analytical
experiment but something went wrong and
the star charts to get him back home are
in Daviess brain so that means the
control the ship is now under Davy and
he makes a deal that if max can get him
back home he'll give him the starch
Arthur in his brain everyone likes to
say the film is split into two halves
the first half being a lot of buildup
and a lot of science talk and the second
half which is a straightforward kids
movie with the kid enjoying the
spaceship and talking with the alien
life-form telling jokes all that fun
stuff and that is true for a kid they
work out perfectly for an adult the
first half is definitely a lot better
than the second half the build-up is
just so friggin good I love watching
this movie with a person who's never
seen it or even heard of it before and
watching that scene where they have the
computers hooked up to his head David
where have you been for the last eight
years I don't know
the look on audience's faces when that
word pops up is always great again it's
just an idea of how good the build up is
and kids won't find it that boring
because the focus is still on the boy
it's all from his point of view so
you're okay wanting to follow him and
the second half like I said is
delivering the kids what they want to
see a boy on a spaceship flying around
having fun and don't get me wrong it's
still good I mean there's nothing wrong
with it at all it's just man with that
build up you're thinking it's gonna add
up to something like Close Encounters of
the Third Kind or something really large
but then it can snaps you back oh yeah
kids Phil but the heck there's nothing
wrong with that just because it did one
element of the film way too well doesn't
mean that the second half is gonna be
anything really that bad that's Paul
Rubens as Max and he does a really good
job playing both the very serious Dern
computer and also the sort of fun-loving
goofy side that part gets injected into
my scans Davies brain if I did have a
problem I'd say that the kid himself is
a little bit of a wimp
I get the feeling the part was written
for a younger role like maybe six or
seven but this kid looks somewhere
between 11 and 13 and I don't know I
just don't see 11 or 13 year old crying
this much or whining this much or being
this afraid when he'd be at that age
where he wants to get these answers he
wants to know what's going on but aside
from that this film is great it has
wonderful build-up it has a really fun
second-half it's got some damn good
effects and it balances out with just
enough ideas and intrigue with fun and
goofiness I can see people being turned
off by having a much better stronger
have this I can have but if you go in
remembering that this was a movie mostly
intended for families I think you'll
enjoy if I find out for yourself as you
are